your wardrobe is like basically I don't  give a [ __ ] I realize that I get hot a  lot I don't like wearing t-shirts and so  I ended up wearing beaters all the time  it's cooler I was like great I just  eliminated an entire set of things from  my closet just made my life so much  simpler on that side I was like I wonder  what else I can eliminate I wonder if I  could just find a shoe that I would  never have to wear socks for and I work  out in the shoe can I walk in the shoe I  bought like 40 pairs of shoes on Amazon  that were all barefoot shoes and I ended  up liking Crocs the most and then George  I can work out in I can work in and I  think they really convey an idea of  class to the audience I think so too  very systematic and very practical